yes everything's racist should Dems with
seniority give their seats to minorities
a guest essay in the Washington Post
argues that white Democrats including
Katie Porter and Adam Schiff should drop
out of California Senate race to prove
that they care about diversity Steve
Phillips writes quote they need to know
and show that forcing genuine equality
isn't easy or comfortable it requires
hard decisions especially for white
people who might have to disappoint
their friends or sacrifice their egos
and Ambitions for the sake of the larger
cause here here so if they refuse I
guess that makes them racist but there's
no chance shiff or Porter would
willingly leave Congress history shows
that white Democrats don't like to give
up their seats for black people just ask
Rosa Parks Dam yeah I know but hey this
is the kind of identity politics that
liberals like Schiff and Porter always
encourage as Joe Biden always says
you've made your bed now you have to pee
in
it Tyrus this is a great point if you're
say you're a white person and you're all
for Equity you your job then should be
filled by a person of color why doesn't
all the people who are pro the white
people who are pro Equity step
aside that's
Greg they
were I didn't really mean take my job
that's right what would you guys even do
in this job you got to read and know Ma
and we clearly proved you don't so no we
give you the inconsequential jobs and
Pat you on the head I love this they
turn they turned it on the virtue
signals yeah and now they turn around
well why are you running yeah yeah and
now they they don't know what to do
because guess what they're not going to
not run so now they're going to say I'll
tell you what my interns will be a a
black lesbian
[Laughter]
man
Miss
yeah they exist and I say they proper
one I am one of them sorry for outing
you today I'm one of them that is they
put look at the makeup on only when you
wear that shirt man yes this is a black
lesbian man's
shirt I borrowed from him this morning I
didn't want to wake him
though rip Charles P yeah Dan denan this
argument is impeccable how do you get
around it oh I actually worked how you
get around it okay so in in with
Democrats everything and you talk about
this is move you have to figure out a
way to move up the power pyramid of
adversity so the more oppressed and
marginalized groups that you belong to
the higher up you rise in the inter it
right so you race is hard to fake listen
Elizabeth Warren figured this out a long
time ago she just got busted race is
hard to fake but not you can switch your
gender like boom you don't even have to
take the hormones yeah um
you so all that money I SP your sex your
sexuality look at Sammy Britton yeah you
know the lady dress and Luggage Thief So
Adam Schiff can immediately become
a
lesbian
zoroastrian with fractious bowels
because you have to have like some sort
of like health problem fraes bowels that
seems like something mathematic no you
can't digest uh algebra no just you know
chronic
chronic lesbian he I mean he doesn't
he's already got red cheeks I mean
that's not a big leap zor asrian nobody
knows what Zoroastrianism is and then
he's got like chronic liquid diarrhea
there you go well that's
delicious Joey uh they've gotten to the
point now where all you got to do is
tick a box right well Adam Schiff has
bowel problems because he's full
of what is it with pooping you
people your bed you laying it yeah um
here's the deal I I brought this more
micro I'm looking at this actual Senate
race he was talking about you have three
players here you have Adam Schiff ktie
Porter and Barbara Lee and I just want
to say on behalf of white people I'm
sorry man that's not the best we can do
I mean barbar Lee probably is the best
candidate in that group race aside that
yeah it's true but here's the deal you I
am a heterosexual I believe that's the
right term white man you know straight
white man and you know I I was born that
way I didn't mean to be I didn't choose
it uh it just kind of well at least
three quarters of one anyway
and let me tell you everything I have
I've earned and if you want it come take
it and and if you are better than me and
and work harder than me I'll support you
in it and that's how we should all look
at it there
are there are kids uh minority kids in
in Desperate situations that deserve to
be invested in that's how you fix a
diversity problem not by getting Elder
elderly or or older uh eth
people of other ethnicities and saying
ah well you deserve it more MH you know
Tom when you go to your late night
meetings with the
KKK do they discuss whether or not the
head should step aside for a minority
yeah it's the Kanas club
grg uh it's the Kim Kardashian I can't I
get confused yes I white people can't be
Senators anymore that was I thought that
was the last thing we were good
for I I'm so glad I work for you Greg I
mean my Heyday in the '90s I could
actually make a living doing commercials
back when people liked white people and
I could be like hey I'm white guy eating
spaghetti oh that's great and then there
was like 10 years where I could play the
dumb Dad yes so I survived on that and
now I can't do anything except be the
bad guy in the Simply Safe
commercial it's true I'm like what or a
serial killer in any movie yeah I can do
that too you're like the architect in
every Law and Order episode true first
they falsely accuse a homeless man
and then by the by the third commercial
break it's you yeah actually I'm working
on my uh Columbo villain look here with
yes exactly Columbo any more questions
just one more thing uh the I think Adam
Schiff though he should just go full
alien he should say he's from another
planet
yes that that trumps all the other race
stuff and because I can't decide who
he's more like Marvin the Martian from
Warner Brothers yeah or Gazo from The
Flintstones you know he has a bit of a
Gazoo hey
dummies
but sound like Dr Smith from Lost in
Space yeah he does have a little bit of
Dr Smith too who does the pain the
pain or my first husband
yeah hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it and anywhere
else